i'm with my best partner ever this
sensational
hi everybody happy holidays oh let's get
right into our cake news of the day
i hope you're ready for breakfast here
we go cake of the day graphic
design all right today's top cake uh
in the news bobcat now this would be my
first vodka experience i've never had it
before
bobcat for breakfast tonight is the
first night of hanukkah
and we're celebrating early you know my
daughters are half jewish
i didn't know that absolutely we'll be
lighting the menorah tonight
heartbread part cake bob cut is a
delicious part of the jewish food
experience and the new york food
experience babka means little
grandmother in yiddish which i never
knew
no i found out that just now i know
sorry little grandma though
we're gonna have to eat chat this is
delish it's all about there's a little
cinnamon there i think
too and some chocolate very excited okay
we have some breaking news ross
this just happened during commercial
break we heard this i know i'm really
excited
so of course i ate some bob cuts you
take this you're gonna tell everybody
okay
anybody here love taylor swift hi yes i
love her so much
me too and do you remember when she
surprised us with folklore that album in
the middle of pandemic yes i love her so
much
well breaking news taylor swift is
dropping another brand new album
tonight at midnight set your watch
she just announced it on twitter
and drew's just a little bit excited it
is her ninth studio album she was just
nominated for album of the year for
folklore right and
she says it's the sister regular record
to for folklore and this one's called
evermore i'm so into it i can't even i'm
excited we have
breaking news okay this week a
mother-daughter pair gave us a special
look into their relationship
and i love this today reports a mom
noticed her daughter's dirty sock on the
bathroom floor for over a week
so she put up a museum placard next to
it writing
the forgotten sock mixed media on loan
from the collection of the artist
hilarious i mean this is so clever and
cool and then her daughter
hit back with and and enhance the
exhibit
by introducing a tiny pedestal yeah mom
i see you and i'll one-up you with a
pedestal
i just love this so much are your are
your daughters messy like this
oh i mean if this is the case then
olive's room is the natural history
museum and frankie's room is the lube
because yes girls are messy yeah i was
always a clean kid i was
a toddler version of like mr clean meets
judy garland i was a nice little tidy
kid
really i wouldn't lie to you i i i
really had to learn domesticity on my
own
and laundry really saved my life and i
wrote a chapter of it
uh in the book i wrote because i was
like 14 when i moved out on my own and i
didn't know you had to like throw food
away in the fridge there was like spores
and science experiments how would you
know that at 14 right yeah
but i learned domesticity and it really
does
you know elevate um my mood
i love doing chores around the house
like cleaning is a very
zen totally beautiful art totally like
olive and frankie don't get that yet
maybe they'll get it at 14 15. maybe
they'll
pick it up from you i hope so
[Music]